ah non mais je peux plus les promenades
on ne peut pas dire ça c'est comme un
peu véro véronique fournier quoi vous
savez il vous adore les enfants et les
enfants adorent tout le temps c'est fou
de toutes les normes qu'ils ont et vous
êtes leur préférée c'est bien simple
d'ailleurs j'y pense c'est bête parce
qu'en fait il vous avait prévenu
peut-être la dernière fois qu'il me voit
comme voulait plus d'eux eh ben ils vont
vous le faire tout de suite
allez les enfants 2 3 dans son
deux-pièces bien décorée elle nous
regarde l hiver et été et nous faisait
plein de bize nous l on gardait toute la
semaine et c'est tant mieux tellement
aullène fallait s'occupera toujours de
nous les lois maman n'a plus d'argent à
vienne en 16e et boxer ça va ça va hein
c'est bon c'est bon je voulais pas réglé
la semaine prochaine sauf merci du fond
du coeur attendez attendez attendez là
il ya une erreur on est fonctionnaire on
peut pas de licencier cabanon bas nous
n'avons jamais rien n'est pas
fonctionnaire non écoute cathy je
travaille à l' agence pour l'emploi
depuis dix ans je suis fonctionnaire au
travail agence pour l'emploi mais tu es
pas on n'est pas fonctionnaire non non
pas roussillon ne fonctionnerait leur
ans et va tomber dans votre vieux
l'autre l'emploi aurait fonctionnerait
pas pâtir de vente loyer on a employé un
regard dans les statuts sais pas c'est
pas dans les statuts on est des employés
comme les autres on peut admirer comme
tout le monde on n'est rien dans la
société tav a compris j'ai toujours
voulu sanctionner toute la journée on
traite d'enculé de fonctionnaires tu as
fini par le croire
c'est quand même dommage on est là je
connais ta situation récente tu connais
la mienne
un petit peu bête on n'est pas resté
malheureux chacun de notre côté alors
qu'on allait tous les deux les organes
qu'il faut pour donner du plaisir non
pas pardon je veux pas te fout tout une
collègue
oui enfin on est des collègues m'ont
aussi de me faire un nom mais dis donc
c'est fou quand même
j'y crois pas t'as pas de morale tu as
la gueule à magnum était coincée du cul
tu vois dans un autre monde sans tout ça
à toi et moi on aurait pu être à mon
frère et soeur t'as pas vu mon slip
nouvelle vous n'êtes plus demandeurs
d'emploi n'arrive pas mac tu as lisez
pas au téléphone votre cerveau ne
fonctionne pas pour une actualisation
trois avoue toi on vous soit wah wah
vous dit toi j'ai pas dis toi j'ai dis
toi même elle vous demande de dire 3 3
comme de plus en paix et c'est ce que je
dis poids j'admets que sur le de vous
seriez plus à l'esm est bon 3 c3 du
patois
vous n'aimez pas les noix au contraire
j'adore tous les fruits secs raciste
raciste connard
com
s'en sortir phalène du père a retrouvé
quelque chose a tendance à plutôt bayrou
peut pas vous n'êtes pas grave c'est
rien c'est quoi votre petit nid j'adore
ce prénom martin à la montagne martine à
la plage est aussi partenaire la ferme
tout à fait je vais leur empire moi mais
mon petit doigt
tout le monde croit martin qui l'a fait
c'est quoi le petit mot de passe martin
et minette comme mayotte c'est joli ça
vous avez une petite chatte martin